hey guys this is des the founder think
Carol and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book in video game guru
and this is our review of Breaking Bad
season five it's not the premiere but it
is it's the busy heart too yes exactly
Blood Money Blood Money owners is its
season 5 episode 9 the last the last
eight episodes so yeah this episode it's
a setup episode yes not too much really
happens until the end but it's like a
lot of stuff that thats sets things up
and like last the first episode of
season five it starts with a flash
forward yeah i like i like seeing the 54
we see wall approaching his condemned
house it looks like you know he still
got the big gun in the back of the trunk
so i'm assuming is probably maybe right
after the diner he's going there and
looking around to the Heisenberg and big
yellow letter or somebody's trash his
house got kids you know doing some
skateboard in the back so in the rice
and of course cousin difficult to focus
which we knew was gonna come with this
you know and the V we did just a little
while ago about our predictions its back
it's gonna play a role again maybe we
already have now this is my prediction
look at it looked like there was a
little bit less in it really um then
present day you nor I you know Kurt not
not not the flash for it so maybe I want
to see if he's gonna use it again than
before you know we get to that new point
that's a speculation but no it's glad to
see it yeah it's interesting to the
house it's for clothes and one year
we've got tore down yeah I mean they
like some like you know neighborhood
watch or something I mean it is messed
up yeah so then we come back to regular
time and we see you know that that you
know Hank has just realized that that
Walt is you know Heisenberg and the big
you know the masterminded by his stuff
and and at first I was worried that he
was gonna try and confront him right
away yes he was slowly walking out of
the bathroom were like well you never
were like no don't do it yeah but but
luckily you smart enough not to but um
yeah I mean he's just kind of messed up
in the head now because it's like this
guy is his family member yeah I thought
who didn't have a heart attack you got
driving the car home there i mean i
guess is just one of those like episodes
like Tony Soprano head or something like
a pan
attack maybe but ya know it's
interesting I mean he's under a lot of
duress and then we come and find Jesse
which in my opinion may be one of the
best moments of dialogue is breaking bad
that I've seen in a while I just love
that him just sitting to the couch
listening to skinny Pete my camera other
guys name the one guy skinny Pete just
discussing this bizarre scenario from
Star Trek The Next Generation is awesome
love's a script of this guy right that
is no good but Jesse's got kind of lost
it down and totally lost it he's trying
to give his money go see salt he's
trying to give his money away it's like
he's trying to buy like some forgiveness
or buy some rice you know he's just he
just he's trying to give money to like
hopefully wash everything that he's done
away but I mean as you know is kind of
messed up that right Walt is in terms of
like lying to him about Mike being alive
and whatnot he is still right like you
shouldn't you can't just drop all this
money off for those two people cuz
people are gonna get suspicious right i
mean is shady as Saul is I mean he had a
point he's like that kids family wants
their son back I don't want two and a
half two and half million dollars just
gonna raise questions it's not gonna
give them their son back that's not what
they want and same with the mic so
granddaughter you're like that's not
gonna help they've already taken her
money like why so those you seeing with
Jesse with wall once they started
talking we see how again how far waltz
fallen wall to just lie after lie after
a lot I would just see what I think this
is the only time where I'm really seen I
mean Jesse's always been kind of
suspicious he knows now but now it's
like straight on he does not that was
like the coldest air I've seen you do in
the show he just looked at his idea like
you said he's gone you know I mean that
was just he knows it won't fly he
doesn't trust him at all no no no no
more mr. white no no more hey mr. white
asking like a little kid anymore yeah
you because I mean even in the last the
first half of the season Jesse he
obviously still had problems and Walter
winner but there were still we bought
him a watch for his birthday you know I
kind of did some nice things for him he
did bring a gun thinking that Walt would
not kill her but even still that was
still there still doubt in his mind
there's no doubt no there's no doubt he
said yeah and then we see Walter again
with the whole trying to go clean
suppose alize you know talking to Scott
about possibly investing in some more
car washes maybe get in a chain going on
up there and of course tickets visit
from wrong and crazy lady yeah Lydia
crazy ladies always like go what he
talked about what he talked about yeah
so maybe yeah yeah she always bugs me
yeah definitely that I think so
apparently you know from from that
conversation we can gather that he's
he's turned over the the business to
todd todd but his purity is only 68% not
good yeah no its back to like the old
you know there's no reason why people
would prefer this over right you know
and I wasn't even see scholar get kind
of like you know upset and like oh I
like sooner do that like seeing her go
talk to us Lydia by the same time Lydia
is crazy like Lydia might not be a
killer but she'll hire somebody to do
something like she did try official show
rat him out oh yeah sure right amount
she'll save her skin and her daughter I
me show ya she doesn't care yeah so yeah
in Skyler's kind of half on board now
that wall has completely quit cuz he has
he stuck up for ya like wall told her
the truth and she stuck up for ya so
yeah and then back to Jesse yeah he said
so now he's just like he giving his
money over Santa Claus yeah well the one
day I'm wondering is like he's throwing
that money out but his fingerprints are
on the money yeah he's throwing like
other random people and giving to the
bomb and so I don't know if that's gonna
you know be visited on or is that just
something that like they'll just gloss
over yeah I feel like it's more of like
a um it seems like this is just him like
letting his emotions out some that money
went the sewer somebody probably the
mold with a lawnmower I mean who knows
he's gonna get that but yeah he's he is
loss co thing cuz he has nothing like
Walt at least has his kids yes well has
sky his family and jesse has nothing I
mean that's the thing I think jesse has
skinny Pete and his other guys smoking
we talking about Star Trek episodes so
so finally at the end we kind of get
this the confrontation I actually
thought this was a bit soon you know I
thought this would happen maybe if you
hadn't yeah right in but but basically
Hank and Walt now know each other yeah
like
won't knows that Hank knows and Hank
knows that won't know Zoe knows yeah
because of the tracking device or
anything so yeah I personally thought it
was gonna happen a few episodes later
but now it's like you know and waltz
again trying to manipulate him trying to
say hey well what are you gonna do I'm
gonna die anyways 26 months because of
cancers back which apparently looks to
be real I don't think he's lying about
no I mean he was just getting the drip
getting the chemo is I mean yeah I think
he's sick throwing up taking the pills i
mean i think it is back in that way they
introduced it to in part one of season
five we said the diner he little cough
and then this new you know ya sees the
episode 9 here he's coughing too so i
think it probably is coming back yeah no
no he's gonna be dead in six months i
mean he should likely of them like I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be here anyway but i
think it is back yeah but we still don't
know and of course they weren't gonna
reveal we still don't know what you know
this big machine gun the rice and all
right off is leading up to where's his
family like what happens yeah i mean i
don't know it's I think it's gonna be
I'm looking forward it's gonna be good I
mean that showdown between Hank it
Walter was awesome as soon as he closed
that garage door holders like I don't
know if I like the way you look at that
be right I was like oh it's on there's
just a staredown I mean they didn't know
punching but mostly just to stare down
yeah you know beatable he's more
physically powerful than wall oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but then you know Walt at
the end he's like tread lightly right
yeah it was good it's like if he if you
don't know who i am you know right you
know what I've done yeah I mean he's the
one who knocks remember he's what you're
not Walt doesn't mess around either yeah
but then also it's like well let's
there's still no proof right I mean
there's circumstantial evidence that
that Hank has but they're still no I
mean if they can get like someone like
Lydia or talk yeah I see something there
then then you have the evidence but then
well you know was gonna try and kill
let's say like Lydia decides to turn
right oh well it's gonna just try and
get it like offer yeah I mean especially
and it also will go back to Jesse in his
state of mind right now
he would be the one besides Lydia Lydia
is crazy I could see him just being like
I don't care anymore I don't care about
life anymore I'm just gonna tell
everybody everything and try to you know
yeah he's he's got a lot of loose ends
well it's got a lot of loose ends a lot
of people gonna be looking for him now
we didn't see him in this episode but we
did see Todd the actor saw his name in
the credits so we should see him at some
point the Seas he's getting credit so we
should see him at some point I hope ya
go pre honesty now I think so yeah I
think he's gonna play into cuz he's the
one who's still we're trying to run the
business right that's not doing that Wow
right and I think yeah maybe he'll turn
or something like that he'll play into
this maybe wall will hire him to kill
someone else like a Lydia next time da
doesn't care he kills kids yeah because
once you feel like a kid there's no
turning back for it yeah alright guys so
that's what we thought of the episode
you can post your comments below on our
website or on our youtube video that and
make sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel it's a think here I'll pro and
you also can find us on twitter i'm at
griffin de and i'm at think hero and
also we have a facebook page that's a
facebook.com slash think hero fans
you